from j hud to jessica to the wolverine
some big stars stepped out at radio city
music hall in new york for broadway's
biggest nights an emmy grammy oscar and
now a tony yes jennifer hudson is now
the 17th member of the prestigious egot
club and the tony goes to a strange
league
the multi-talented star picked up the
award when a strange loop won for best
new musical as she's a producer on the
show also a producer on the pulitzer
prize winning play and winning his first
tony rupaul and it was a big night for
the lehman trilogy and company which
tied with the most awards with five each
this is just an incredible honor hugh
jackman was all smiles as he looked
dapper in a tom ford tux on the red
carpet as he posed with his music man
co-star sutton foster later the two
dazzled the crowd as they performed an
energetic tap dancing performance of 76
trombones
[Applause]
a fun night for hugh even though he lost
the tony award for best actor in a
musical to broadway newcomer miles frost
for mj about the life of michael jackson
i really gotta pee right now so i keep
it quick showing their support were
michael's two children paris and prince
jackson who introduced a performance
from the hit musical a lot of people
seem to think our dad michael jackson
changed popular music forever and who
are we to disagree jessie tyler ferguson
had a lot to celebrate the modern family
star picked up his first ever tony
winning for best featured actor in a
play for take me out mom dad thank you
for letting me move to new york when i
was 17 years old i told you it'd be okay
but awards host ariana debose may have
stolen the show as she got her dance on
with nominee sam rockwell
and then weaved her web around
spider-man himself andrew garfield